I went to riyafest for the first time in
Chicago I specifically decided not to do
Lollapalooza this year because the Riot
Fest lineup was just out of control and
boy
I love this Festival because there is so
much brand Integrity they do such a
great job of of
adhering to what we always call Brand
values but I can't even call these
values but the way that the brand sort
of cuts through and is almost cooler
than anything that happens around it is
the part that I like the most I mean you
can't walk 10 feet without somebody
having a Riot Fest socks shirt on
and you know if you if you are there are
there's a few festivals in that City
like Pitchfork
um that I think that
people always tend to to gravitate
towards anything that's not Lollapalooza
is where the cool kids go and and boy uh
I don't know if I've ever seen so many
black shirts everybody's got a black
shirt on at Riot Fest if you wear a
pastel
at Riot fast I think you're getting
booed out of the place
um there's just a couple things about it
that like other than so I think that the
the actual engagement of it is fantastic
uh I think that their their brand is
really special and interesting man guys
I
it may be in the worst location in
America
uh getting to Douglas Park is fine but
getting out of it you literally have to
wake up in the morning and the first
thing that you have to think about is
getting out of Riot Fest
you have to plan your entire day on how
and when you're getting out of this
Festival there's no easy way out good
luck getting an Uber and it's not that
it's just so far away but apparently
it's the same weekend every weekend as
the Mexican parade and what does the
Mexican parade it's it's not a parade
it's just flooding the streets with cars
and flags you're what four miles away
from the loop in Chicago
it took one of our guys two hours after
the festival just to get four miles to
the east to his hotel
tours it's because every street around
you
is redlined I mean you look at the the
traffic pattern it's nothing but red
oh boy is it a so we're leaving the
first night and because
we had to plan getting out we had to
leave the Foo Fighters set and not early
enough to get out
um and get back to a whole group of
people that we had to meet up it was a
big radio sort of thing but
we leave and thank God for this Uber
driver if I could remember his name I
would send him money on venmo because he
was so kind he's weaving In and Out In
and Out block streets closed streets
he'd found just the right way we take a
left we finally get to open road
we're almost so close to our destination
and we're going about 35 miles an hour
down the Chicago Street and out of
nowhere he screeches the brakes
I we might have screeched I don't know
20 30 feet
to
the crosswalk where a woman is standing
in the middle of the road
taking a picture
taking a picture of the skyline didn't
even see a car coming didn't realize it
was a green light
and it was one of those moments where
the car screeches and her two hands slam
the front of the of the car and stares
at everybody in the car
like she just saw her life flash before
her eyes it was like a movie like
and of course what do you do if you're
in the car and you almost kill someone
[Music]
I had it loaded on my tongue
there's a woman that almost died but yet
we're screaming obscenities at them
literally a car we had seven people in
the silver just screaming at this person
as if we're the ones that almost died
it was it was so scary it was honestly
traumatic uh watching this woman we
literally almost killed someone
uh that I I I don't know if you've ever
been that close but that just freaked me
out uh all weekend and so
um let's just say the plan to get out
was very very very uh on the top of our
mind come Saturday morning man come
Saturday though come Saturday though you
get death cab and Postal Service and
I'll tell you as a guy who loves Death
Cab it's my favorite band of all times
also my favorite album transatlanticism
of all time
I I I've been going to death cab shows
for 20 years I uh I don't know we I've
seen him I don't know
two dozen three dozen times I've never
heard some of these songs played live uh
this thing is is magical even though
they're only doing the album front to
back and then Postal Service comes on
and does the album front to back they
add a remix of one of the songs at the
end and they do a cover uh but just
hearing it in sequence
I just I've never heard it before uh and
it was phenomenal the other thing that I
had never heard before live and I don't
know if I ever will again even though
they're playing in New York tonight I
got to see the Breeders you know and you
know they sounded terrible but who I
didn't care I just did not care and they
played their album that their essential
album like front to back and we go with
a whole bunch of people and it's like uh
I don't know who the Breeders are who
are the Breeders who the Breeders we're
all like just wait to the third song
you'll know exactly who they are in the
studio as soon as it hits
uh one piece of criticism about Raya
Fest
you know I hate to be
you know Mr Festival organizer guy here
but we've been to enough of these to
know
where the money is is left on the table
right there are a million beer stands
you can't turn around and not see a beer
stand so they're doing a fantastic job
maximizing their uh Beer Money
possibilities but there's no food
good luck finding a food vendor not a
single food vendor anywhere
in the main area now you can buy a ton
of merch you can buy a ton of beer you
have to walk damn near a mile and a half
to the other end of the entire Festival
into a corner that nothing else is there
but a ferris wheel it would be like if
all the food at Bonnaroo was only at
where in the woods wow you had to walk
all the way to where in the woods just
to eat and imagine if you're at imagine
if you're at the other
and you have to walk to where the woods
to buy a sandwich and you're starving
and you're trying to get you're trying
to eat before the next show
yeah and then when you get there the
line is everybody's there I don't know
25 deep
it is it is one of the missed
opportunities of this Festival otherwise
you know the grounds are really nice but
boy trying to trying to get Douglas
parking but the other thing about
Douglas Park is that um by the way it's
not the best part of town
um getting there is fine you know I
people suggested taking Divi bikes there
um you know I know you can do their uh L
the pink line there uh and ubering there
is actually quite easy and and fairly
inexpensive especially at the time that
you're doing it but getting back I mean
good luck uh it's it's a coin flip on
what you can and can't get uh good luck
getting an Uber unless you leave early
Divi bikes are all gone you might be
able to get a a scoot scoot good luck I
don't know um but it's so hard to get
out some people swear by the pink line
but you're still you're jammed in there
and you're going to be on that train for
an hour
it's just a tough location it's a really
really tough place and the worst part
and this is the part I I forgot to
mention nobody in that neighborhood
wants a thing
so you can't walk anywhere outside of
Douglas Park and not see graffiti all
over the the fencing saying get out of
our neighborhood
they have taken over a predominantly
black neighborhood that really utilizes
this park on a on a daily basis and
um it's it's not wanted uh so you I
don't know maybe I was overthinking it a
bit but leaving that's why I was like I
I don't know where this goes because
they don't want us nobody wants them
here they don't want the the parking
taken over by this Festival
I don't I don't know it's it's a tough
one you know we talked about Governor's
Ball and how their location issues have
lasted for a decade and they finally get
a good spot in Queens
is beloved beloved by the people that go
every year I I just don't know how it
keeps surviving in that way I keep
thinking I was thinking about Governor's
Ball but I was also thinking about you
and I at uh Forecastle you know when the
storm hit and you were talking about
your Uber driver
and I I don't know if you had the same
image but you remember we we called that
Uber driver to come and get us and he
was stuck in traffic and in my mind it
was like Roger Rabbit Roger Rabbit where
he he's coming down and he said I see
you I see you and he comes out of the
light and it like he was on two wheels
and he pulled over in front of us and we
hopped in
I'll never forget that but uh
yeah that is
is really interesting you say it that
way because
Russ and I talked about Moon River which
we're going to talk about here in a
minute which is the Chattanooga Festival
complete opposite I'm not sure every
yeah because it's everything's walking
for everybody in Northern Chattanooga is
thrilled that it's happening that
weekend we have Iron Man here this week
as a matter of fact and it takes
remember Barry as a guy is a guy who
lived in North Chattanooga I loved it I
love the fact that it was literally a
five minute walk from my house I think
the city did a really good job of not
shutting you out right as a as a
resident right you could still get in
and out if you didn't care about it so
those are things that have to be
considered that that's really
interesting to hear you talk about
the fact that the neighbors don't want
it there's nothing worse than top down
where somebody says you know what I I
have decided what you need
right
yeah I I don't know I don't know if
that's how they I would love to try and
find somebody in the Riot Fest world to
talk about it uh I I know that they've
bounced around from location to location
in the past and you know they've been in
Douglas Park the last couple of years
look I don't know if there's many good
options
um in and around the city look you've
got you've got the main Park that lalop
loses on but
um that's really hard it takes a lot of
money I I don't know what the solutions
are but I know Douglas Park is not it
cannot be the long term the music was
good the festival other than the food
fantastic it was it was so well done it
was so well done everywhere else except
for the food situation like all you
gotta do is just drop a couple of food
trucks
around the main part just a I mean just
for Bare Essentials I I just wanted I
just wanted a quick
corn dog give me a give me a cray musty
for Christ's sakes I couldn't even get
that nowhere to be found I mean I think
that's why we do this podcast those are
the kind of things you know can I get a
can I get my ticket can I get in can I
get out can I get a beer can I get
something to eat
and you know am I comfortable I had well
speaking of getting the ticket I mean I
had to go to um
to check in every day right the why am I
blanking on the word when you go get
your tickets uh box office so I head to
the boxer's office both days super easy
very efficient I think they do a really
good operation and you can tell by the
passion that the main Riot Fest people
who go every year they truly love it
that says a lot to me there's just a
little I got little nitpicks I got a
little knits to pick around the around
they cleared out the festival Moon River
you know again but this time not they
didn't cancel cleared it out for an hour
and a half that you know those are the
speaking of kinds of things where you
you know how did how'd they handle it I
thought they handled it well speaking of
the rain so Chicago had a major storm
happen Sunday morning and I wasn't there
Sunday night but my family was and they
said the park barely any mud
I don't know how well they drain that
park or how well that the thing's built
but the fact that you know they they
only ran into a few mud bottles after
torrential downpour and a delayed a
couple hours is really impressive kudos
to the organizers for that kind of stuff
that's that's the kind of stuff that you
know people pay attention to
yeah oh yeah did you see Chloe I did not
actually and and it wasn't until you
told me that she was there that um
that uh I even I I had no idea I know
she wrote me and said that she loves
Raya Fest but I didn't know she was
there until you specifically said so no
I never gotta yeah she goes every year
yeah she's a big fan uh look it's this
is not important to anybody else but
that weekend it could not have been more
perfect the the weather was perfect have
you ever I've used the analogy of like
Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade where
he's going for the Holy Grail and he's
got to cross that invisible bridge and
he doesn't know but every step that he
takes oh my God there's a bridge there's
a bridge here there's a bridge here
that's how it felt every step was
perfect everything worked out perfect I
I couldn't have uh picked a better
weekend